en el último vídeo observamos como la
concentración de azúcar en la sangre
si la glucosa y dijimos que consideramos
normal una medición de 80 miligramos por
decilitro cuando no has comido por 8
horas o antes de comer
si preparan dial y lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es lo siguiente para mí
una concentración de 80 miligramos por
decilitro pues no es una medida muy
tangible y lo que voy a hacer es
convertir esto a otras unidades de
manera que tengamos una idea más clara
de la cantidad de azúcar en nuestra
sangre hagamos un poco de análisis de
unidades por aquí tenemos 80 miligramos
por decilitro como la medida de azúcar
normal en ayuno pero vamos a pensar en
cuánto es esto en términos de litros un
decilitro es la décima parte de un litro
y si lo que quiero hacer es cancelar los
de si litros en el denominador entonces
necesitaré aquí otros decilitros en el
numerador lo que queremos saber son de
si litros por litro esto lo cancelaría
10 decilitros por litro 80 por 10 es 800
los de si litros se cancelan entonces
tenemos 800 miligramos por litro y si
quisiéramos esto en términos de gramos
entonces vamos a multiplicar para
eliminar los miligramos y entonces
ponemos estos miligramos en el
denominador
y queremos gramos sobre miligramos y un
miligramo es una milésima de un gramo
así que otra vez los miligramos se
cancelan y tenemos 800 dividido entre
1800 entre 1000 y 0.8 gramos por litro
lo voy a poner aquí es 0.8 gramos por
litro y ahora si pensamos en un valor
promedio de un peso para un cuerpo de un
ser humano
hice una búsqueda en internet y más o
menos sería de 60 kilogramos
tenemos 5 litros de sangre así que
multiplicaremos esto por 5 litros por
ser humano
bueno es y recuerden que estamos
utilizando el promedio de un ser humano
una persona del cuerpo más pequeño
tendrá menos sangre y una persona
corpulenta tendrá más sangre esta
estimación es para el promedio entonces
dos litros se cancelan y nos quedaría a
punto ocho por 5.8 por 5 entonces 5 por
8 es 40 y me queda entonces 4 gramos por
ser humano y para darnos una idea de
cuánto es estos 4 gramos y podríamos
pensar que una cucharadita si las que
usamos en la cocina es de 4.2 gramos 4.2
gramos así que tenemos aproximadamente
una cucharadita si una cucharadita de
glucosa en nuestro cuerpo en el cuerpo
de un ser humano así que nuestro
torrente sanguíneo tenemos
aproximadamente una cucharadita de
glucosa que servirá para proveer de
energía a nuestras células a todas las
funciones de nuestras células